more trouble this morning for the
e-cigarette maker Joule which is being
sued by another state this time
Massachusetts the state says the company
deliberately targeted young people by
advertising on everything from youth
websites to apps that help kids with
their homework
Massachusetts claims jewel created quote
a public health crisis and an epidemic
of youth nicotine use and addiction CBS
this morning consumer investigative
correspondent and a Werner is here and
at what else does this lawsuit allege
well Tony as you know jewel has long
said that it does not target kids at
targets adults as customers but the
Massachusetts Attorney General's lawsuit
says otherwise prosecutors there say
during Jools launch period executives
rejected a proposed marketing plan that
would have focused on adult smokers and
went with the campaign to target youth
instead these photos showing young
models using Julie's cigarettes come
from an early ad campaign proposal that
the Massachusetts Attorney General says
proofs Jule was out to recruit teenagers
as customers AG Maura Healey Jule was
out there not to try to get adults to
stop smoking but rather to try to get
young people to start vaping
Massachusetts sued Jule Wednesday saying
the company engaged in deceptive and
unfair marketing and sale of its ecig
arete products to youth Healy alleges by
running ads on youth oriented websites
including Nickelodeon the Cartoon
Network and Seventeen magazine the
lawsuit says Jule also sought to enlist
celebrities and prominent social media
users our objective is to be a
responsible player in this market when
we sat down with former Jule executive
Ashley Gould and the company's first
television interview back in 2018 she
insisted those earlier ads were not part
of a deliberate effort to target youth
did the original campaign appeal too
much to younger smokers I can't tell you
if it appealed to kids or not it wasn't
the intention but it's also not
consistent with the way that we're doing
things today in a statement Wednesday
Jewell said it had not yet reviewed the
complaint but is focused on earning the
trust of society by working
cooperatively with attorneys general
regulators and public health officials
combat underage use adding our customer
base is adult smokers Jule unfortunately
through it's very destructive but
effective advertising campaign now has
got a generation of kids hooked and
addicted and jewel needs to pay for that
so far nine state attorneys general have
sued Jule
the company has until made to apply for
FDA approval to stay on the market which
affects other manufacturers so those are
really problematic ads I don't think
anyone would think that that's
acceptable Jule themselves I said look
it was a mistake it's not consistent
with what we're doing now a big problem
for Massachusetts in these other states
is according to the CDC data the
epidemic of e-cigarette use did not
begin with Joule in fact began years
before and in fact e cigarettes overtook
regular cigarettes in 2014 was even on
the market it said that you all is the
one that caught on they came up with the
thing that looks like a USB Drive it's
cool it looks it's kind of like the
iPhone they say later Santa that they
chose some of the names for the flavors
we're very attractive I mean there's a
lot of manufacturers had flavors of
different you know bubblegum and
everything else but they're the ones
that came up with kind of and also they
used a new process for their ISA
Guerette that makes it more like the
feeling you get from smoking a cigarette
so they you know innovated some things
that other people did not and that's why
there's took off and they're the gorilla
in the market well yes we heard the
Attorney General looking for someone to
sue jewelle is the biggest target and
then but when there's doubling and
tripling of the market before jewel
exists there are also regulatory
questions here yes they doing yeah for
sure
alright Anna thank you very much